NARRATOR: Harriet Tubman,
former slave and leader
in the Underground Railroad,
was also a Union spy,
and the first
woman in US history
to lead a military expedition.
Here's how.
After escaping slavery
herself, Harriet Tubman rescued
slaves throughout the 1850s.
And when the Civil War started,
she offered her services
to the Union War Effort.
[music playing]
In 1863, she was assigned
to Colonel James Montgomery
to work for the Union Army
as a nurse, cook, and spy.
[music playing]
Tubman disguised herself
as an aging woman
and moved behind
Confederate lines unnoticed,
gathering information from
a network of informants.
Slaves traded information
in exchange for a chance
of freedom, and sometimes cash.
The covert operation
was approved
by President Abraham
Lincoln and run by Secretary
of State, William Seward.
In South Carolina,
Tubman worked in
Union-controlled
"contraband camps," where
escaped slaves sought safety.
There, she recruited
local informants
and found out where other
slaves were being held.
Tubman and other
spies would gather
Intel about Confederate plans--
[cannons firing]
--such as where they had dropped
barrels filled with gunpowder
to attack Union boats.
On June 1, 1863, alongside
Colonel Montgomery,
she led 300 black soldiers
to raid rice plantations
along the Combahee
River in South Carolina,
making her the first woman
in American history to plan
and lead a military operation.
The soldiers ransacked
the plantation,
setting fire to buildings and
freeing more than 700 slaves.
Tubman continued
to work as a nurse,
cook, and spy for another year.
But she was only paid $200
for her entire war service,
and was never paid
all of the benefits
owed to her, despite
multiple appeals
to the federal government.
It wasn't until 1890, two years
after her husband's death,
that she received a
small pension for being
the widow of a war veteran.
And it wasn't until 1899 that
her pension was increased.
But that didn't make up for
the benefits she deserved.
It would take another
100 years for Tubman
to get the money she was
owed, when in 2002, Congress
was again alerted
about the pension,
and soon after provided $11,750
to the Harriet Tubman Home
in Auburn, New York.
[music playing]